[Music]
hey guys how's it going today we are at
the dr. Oz Show and I am so excited so
I'm a huge dr. Oz fan but my mom is like
super super fan so this is really
exciting not only for me but for my mom
I feel like you guys don't understand
she sends me dr. Oz clips all the time
she will film them on her phone and then
she texts them to uses but good dr. oz
said today about insert topical subject
here basically about anything from
health fitness you know Mike dog tips
and all kinds of things feasibly dr. oz
has covered it all so today I can't
believe it look I love the show they're
here we're about to keep it pretty close
also rehearsals happening yeah
you're going to over the web segment for
dr. otters YouTube channel there's it
really you could channel I will return
an interruption to his channel and to
the video that we're shooting we're
doing at what's the technical the one
thing one thing I know I'm whispering hi
are you be here I think we're about to
go on
[Applause]
we just finished up we got a bunch of
fun segments this is such a fun show I
had such a great time I can't wait for
you guys actually see it
we did one it's sort of like a kitchen
sale kind of like special something out
that I've never tried before and we
tried it out you'll see what happens
actually on the show that with all the
links the description and the
foretellers residence quitter where you
can watch live dr. oz would be back and
we're going to have the quick room chat
with him and see what he has to say
dr. oz how are you I'm better than I got
to know your little now I gotta say I
understand how just he makes so many
errors she tricked me with eggs she was
a judge ruthlessly evaluating two
world-famous chefs but I still love her
yeah it was pretty crazy so I mean my
favorite thing is kind of like in the
kitchen and you you learn by mistake
you know that's really surgery kidding
I'm kidding
oh I was like no no no not what did you
like the most about the judging part
excels the judging part it was actually
great because I love seafood so both of
these chefs made two incredible dishes
I don't how they did that so quickly I
know and the best part was we we tricked
them right I knew I knew they would buy
what they wanted to make yes but would
they be able make the other person yeah
it was great I can't wait for anything
but the best part was that scrambled
eggs trick you showed me I never thought
that was going to work in a million
years it's a pretty fun trick and you
guys will have to see it but there's so
many different kitchen hacks to and
different text things please can you
guys even cover to it I've learned more
from my wife is really gracious who
taught my daughter Daphne you know host
to chew I learned a lot from them just
about how to talk about food
and Lander thought when it comes with
them I know how to eat it exactly gonna
describe it usually yeah I mean we know
what is good but it's like how do you
make it fit control we're gonna take a
backstage and make some more big
mistakes okay no pressure make oh my
gosh I can go the way can you yes I'll
challenge you other the loss can you
juggle yeah all right let's do it
really great yeah but there's there are
other ones I know okay this is great for
the afternoon show tomorrow
all right this is very okay not to take
a tour backstage here I want to show you
this this is getting ready for a b12
show that now the brain works there
before we juggle before we double that's
how you break postal work oh nothing
twelve like that there we go Oh anyway
WZ you are you ready yes I am all right
show us on go no these are juggler oh
[Music]
this is so much easier now there have
your eggs alright guys we should go
check out dr. Oz's YouTube camera giving
YouTube channel I Darryl I'm trying to
check up what I just seen check hers out
for fun I also heard you ruined Twitter
yes yes that is all use a really long
time because your super exciting to
perform on Twitter and Instagram and all
over the Internet
it's Stan the man oh okay it's so cute
to scan when he's been in the hangover
she's doing commercials but she just
told us he's actually retired because
he's too tall to fit in the screen now
so this little boys living retired live
later it's one day wait in advance